contrairement à ce que certains peuvent
penser il peut être avantageux pour
certaines personnes de toucher leurs
rentes de retraite dès l'âge de 60 ans
environ la moitié des québécois le fond
comparativement à moins du tiers des
canadiens des autres provinces
c'est ce que conclut une nouvelle étude
de l'institut de recherche sur les
politiques publiques alors je reçois le
directeur de cette étude dire car le
michaud qui est aussi professeur
d'économie appliquée hec montréal
bonjour monsieur michaud bonjour alors
60 ans et l'âge d'admissibilité pour les
prestations du rrq dites-nous pour qui
l'âge optimale pour toucher et justement
ces prestations est de 60 ans
écoutez il ya trois types de personnes
qui ce qu'ils peuvent se retrouver dans
cette situation là il ya les gens qui
pour toutes sortes de raisons une
espérance de vie plus faible donc à ce
moment leur retard dès la rentrée où il
augmente la rente mais peut-être pour
plus d'années donc c'est un premier
groupe
un deuxième groupe b on le voit
peut-être avec la pandémie ce sont des
gens qui peuvent avoir des besoins de
liquidités importantes et donc ces gens
là on a beau leur dire que ça peut être
intéressant de retarder cette rentrée
pour eux c'est peut-être une bonne chose
et finalement un troisième groupe qui
est quand même très important c'est tout
les gens j'irais là c'est difficile de
fixer une limite mais qui gagne environ
50 mille dollars les moins un revenu de
travail donc quand il demande la vente
ces gens là ils doivent prendre en
compte qu'à partir de 65 ans à ce que
cette rentrée soit récupérée c'est à
dire que d'autres prestations fédérales
qui vont être réduites
donc à partir de ce moment les donc la
bonification est beaucoup moins
intéressant et en contrepartie pour qui
est ce que c'est plutôt avantageux
d'attendre mossé michaud les gens qui
ont essentiellement les moyens de le
faire doit voir la rendre comme un
placement ont fait qu'on retarde la
rente d'une année on sacrifie des
prestations aujourd'hui donc c'est comme
si on investissait dans un produit qui
nous rapporte bon an mal an environ + 10
% annuellement il s'est investi sans
risque alors vous et moi si on a
retrouvé des investissements comme ça on
va seulement de trouver des très risqué
à ce moment là donc c'est vraiment une
question placement dans ce cas là et des
ménages qui ont par exemple suffisamment
de vr qui ont suffisamment d'epargne
d'accumuler c'est un investissement
qu'il faut
sur leurs commandes et je le dit
d'entrée de jeu monsieur michaud la
moitié des québécois touchent leurs
rangs des 60 ans mais pour le reste des
canadiens dans les autres provinces et
moins du tiers comme on explique la
différence
alors on a eu beau fouiller on a trouvé
deux trois pistes mais pour vous dire
que c'est ça qui est intéressant avec la
recherche des fois c'est quand on creuse
et puis il va falloir creuser davantage
mais je vous donne des pistes la
première c'est qu'à partir du milieu des
années 90 on a eu des départs massifs au
québec on va traître anticipé surtout
dans les régimes à prestations
déterminées donc le fait que les
québécois reçoivent davantage et
toujours aujourd'hui il ya plus de gens
couverts par ces régimes la font en
sorte qu'ils étaient des gens qui
partent donc à l'âge de 60 ans et qui
débutent les rentes à ce moment là dans
le sas et un premier groupe une première
piste
deuxième piste c'est qu'à l'aide sociale
à partir du et le milieu des années 90
j'ai une clientèle ou au ministère de
l'emploi qui passe de l'aide sociale
vers le régime des rentes du québec rrq
on les encourage fortement à le faire à
60 ans ça peut être une deuxième piste
qui expliquent la plus haute prévalence
au québec de gens qui apprennent à 60
ans et finalement à partir de 2010 au
québec on donne un formulaire simplifié
aux gens qui ont 59 ans pour demander la
rentrée ça ce prix là c'est une
conjecture à se prononcer ça se peut que
ce l'envoi du formulaire qui se fait pas
dans le reste du canada
ça se fait qu'il incite plusieurs
personnes à prendre la vente à 60 ans et
pour ceux qui ne le touche pas tout de
suite quelle est la moyenne d'âge à peu
près mais c'est michaud donc ceux qui
attendent le de prendre la rentrée il y
en a plusieurs qui vont attendre
seulement quelques années donc une ou
deux donc on peut penser que ce sont des
gens qui pensent en termes
d'investissements et il ya d'autres gens
qui vont attendre jusqu'à 65 à 66 ans il
ya même des gens qui attendent jusqu'à
70 ans on sait que l'espérance de vie
est en progression on vit plus de plus
en plus longtemps après s'être retiré du
marché du travail
est-ce qu'il serait bien sont voués
selon l'étude de haut c'est justement
l'admissibilité aux prestations ou non
on peut le faire mais c'est un égal
parce que notre système social fait en
sorte que beaucoup de gens qui reçoivent
des prestations dernier recours autour
de l'âge de 60 ans donc ils vont du
perdant
dans un changement comme ça donc on peut
le faire c'est bien motivés mais il va
falloir réfléchir au système dans son
ensemble un peu comme le débat qu'on a
eue sur la pension du gouvernement
donc c'est le même genre d'idée le
système de retraite est compliquée et au
talent et au niveau fédéral que
provincial il doit avoir des discussions
pour s'assurer qu'il ya personne qui
perd dans ce changement comme ça alors
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire si on veut
inciter par exemple les québécois
attendre un petit peu plus longtemps
avant de toucher les prestations
je pense qu'il faut d'abord communiquer
beaucoup mieux il faut éduquer les gens
donc aider en termes d'éducation ne
s'est pas un blanc qui ont fait auprès
des consommateurs ce sont des enjeux
difficile des décisions difficiles et
donc on a un gros travail d'éducation au
niveau financier et deuxièmement c'est
clair qu'on peut améliorer la
flexibilité dont de la prise la rente
retrait en ce moment à ce moment si les
ménages se trouve un peu pris entre
l'arbre et l'écorcé à dire soit ils
apprennent à 60 où ils attendent c'est
un peu irréversible il ya des moyens
potentiellement d'améliorer la
flexibilité du système pour permettre de
rendre progressif car michaud merci
beaucoup
ça m'a fait plaisir à voir au revoir